so ähnlich schon geschenke einfach
irgendwelche schritte seit nun fast drei
jahren sind ihre beiden töchter weg
geblieben ist eine schmerzhafte lehre
war erfüllt von hoffnung war von
hoffnungslosigkeit während das eigene
leben davon fließt wenn das
unerträgliche erträglich wird
davon handelt dieser film
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir beginnen diese geschichte im
dezember 2015 mit der reise nach ägypten
es ist die geschichte von karin traxel
im kampf um ihre töchter ist die
lehrerin von interlaken nach kairo
gezogen wohin ihr ex mann die damals
zwei und vierjährigen mädchen entführte
bei unserer ankunft schien ein happy end
möglich nach wochenlangem ringen konnte
karin traxel ihre töchter endlich wieder
sehen und die ältere durch einen handel
mit ihrem ex mann sogar zurückgewinnen
es ist offensichtlich die monate der
trennung führten zu entfremdung die
angst davor mehr und die klinik gar
nimmer und die größere wenig deutsch
verstand er ja nur probiert sich mit
europäischem methan dafür ist
komplizierter zum sie es ist
weihnachtszeit wie früher zu hause in
interlaken so backen die beiden auch
hier in ihrem zufluchtsort gemeinsam
gritti bands aus furcht ihr ex mann
könne ihr nur an wieder entreißen hält
karin traxel sich und ihre ältere
tochter in der millionenmetropole kairo
versteckt trotz ausnahmezustand will die
mutter der tochter ein stück heile welt
ermöglichen vollständig aber ist der
mutter glück nur zu dritt wie auf diesem
foto von früher
es fehlt die jüngere tochter sarah
geburtstag des telefonierens probiert
derzeit geburtstag war nicht wieder weg
so oder so schwierige tage das eigene
kind weg wie lässt sich das ertragen
hoffnung so lautet zu diesem zeitpunkt
der geschichte die antwort karen traxel
ließ nichts unversucht hat bei den
schweizer und ägyptischen behörden
wiederholt angeklopft den gerichtlich
gegen ihren ex-mann vor
doch nach ägyptischem gesetz hat der
vater keine straftat begangen
jetzt aber scheint ihre chance gekommen
mit hilfe eines anwalts will karin
traxel ihr auch in ägypten zugesprochene
sorgerecht einfordern und die jüngere
tochter sarah holen
doch statt im glück endet diese aktion
im hinterhof bei einem mittelsmann
ihr ex-mann hat dem richter ein foto von
ihr und einem anderen mann vorgelegt
vertan dass die mutter sich neu bindet
riskiert sie das sorgerecht zu verlieren
ich weiß nicht was das für ein foto ist
sie müssen klären wer dieser mann war
und zu welcher gelegenheit sehen
getroffen haben
das ist sehr wichtig und wieder ein
rückschlag auch wenn sich später
herausstellt das foto stammt aus karin
praxis uni zeit und zeigt sie mit einem
mit studenten an der fasnacht die
hoffnung auf eine rückkehr zu dritt
wurde soeben zerschlagen und es kommt
noch schlimmer
[Musik]
ein halbes jahr später besuchen wie im
berner oberland die großmutter der
entführten kinder mehrmals am tag
schreibt sie mit ihrer tochter karin
die immer noch in kairo ist die
verzweiflung hat mittlerweile ihren
höhepunkt erreicht
mithilfe von komplizen hat die ex mann
karin traxel und nur an auf dem weg zum
schulbus überfallen
was passiert
wenige wochen später nimmt diese
geschichte eine wende am flughafen genf
warten karin traxel tante und cousine
angespannt auf den flug aus kairo
auch sie haben während der letzten
monate mitgelitten und karin traxel
moralisch unterstützt
die anspannung ist spürbar
endlich nach zehn monaten allein in der
fremde ist karin traxel wieder daheim in
der schweiz aber ohne ihre kinder
die wiedersehensfreude lässt die bittere
wirklichkeit für einen flüchtigen moment
vergessen
es soll nur ein kurzer aufenthalt in der
schweiz werden
die versicherung will karin trachsel
situation neu beurteilen
bislang war sie als lehrerin
krankgeschrieben und ihre mutter wurde
am herzen operiert vom flughafen geht es
auf direktem weg ins spital
nein ich meine sache jetzt so meine ich
mir wieder durchlässig der leben
technische markiert was sie nicht
belastet wird auf die straße
die gerichtsverhandlung umgang mit man
sich jetzt noch 20 oder grund warum man
sich an
irgendwo mit dem taxi muss ich eben das
sitzen in abrahams nicht sofort steht am
nächsten tag ist die euphorie der
wiedersehensfreude nicht mehr spürbar
karin traxel scheint erschöpft mutlos
das habe die raue wirklichkeit ihren
kampfgeist abgeschliffen antidepressiva
und schlafmittel helfen die kinder
fehlen denn noch immer wie holte sie das
muss wie machen sie daraus dauert sie
und klingt eine zukunft mehr ab dass man
es wirklich so einfach
aber die rückenstrecken technische
stumpf mit seiner strategie während
ihres aufenthalts von karin traxel im
gästezimmer der eltern die eigene
wohnung hat sie untervermietet richtig
ankommen kann sie sowieso nicht
herz und gedanken sind in ägypten
geblieben
seit ihrer ankunft ist im ständigen
kontakt mit ihrem anwalt vor ort heute
morgen konnte die schweizer botschaft in
sachen traxel beim ägyptischen
sicherheitsdienst vorsprechen von den
beiden mädchen fehlt seit dem überfall
jede spur
sie sagen sie würden ihm zu verfolgen
aber er sei sehr wachsam und vermeide
den kontakt zu den kindern licht am
horizont was gott
juli dort geht es darum zu sich die
zweite instanz also bayerische akademie
verurteilt wurde zu einem jahr gefängnis
oder die zweite instanz hoffentlich oder
sollte jetzt bestätigt
auch wenn hoffnung besteht noch ist ihr
ex mann auf freien fuß und ihre töchter
nur an und sarah bleiben unauffindbar
das stinkt sie wollen diese kurzen
momente
zwar mag sie einfach und beobachte ich
vollkommen singles rentner hatte auch
sie bekommt sie die ganze family fix you
lie unbeobachteten moment mit einem
einkommen das bringe nach solange sie wo
sind die mädchen wie geht es ihnen was
machen sie
die mutter hat keine ahnung außer dass
sie seit dem überfall nicht mehr beim
vater leben und er die töchter vor ihr
und den ägyptischen behörden irgendwo
versteckt hält dank halt einfach
klassische schaut dass die sind einfach
darunter mitglied unter dem ganz
konflikt dass zwei shanteau alle pkw
irgendwo ja
unterdessen ist es spätsommer die trucks
kämpfen gegen das vergessen
karins bruder hat eine
benefizveranstaltung organisiert dass
der bruder steht auf der bühne ihr vater
am grill die traxel sammeln
unterschriften für eine petition an
bundesrat didier burkhalter und dass der
patient des äußeren mit der aufforderung
die kinder in die schweiz zurück zu
führen und sie sammeln geld rund eine
halbe million franken hat die familie im
kampf um die kinder ausgegeben
zudem hat die versicherung die zahlungen
an karen traxel aufgrund der
neubeurteilung eingestellt seit ihrer
ankunft sind weitere drei monate
vergangen und obwohl sie
schnellstmöglich nach ägypten zurück
wollte ist kari traxel noch immer hier
warum sind sie nicht
mal bittet zu machen gerade in villach
start geriet roxy neue die renten steht
und da muss er einfach sagen wir
probieren alles möglich aber denkt was
hier musst du das dass die hand geführt
werden aber es bringt mir die fans kein
rassist sagte millionen stoff
[Musik]
seit unserem besuch in ägypten ist
mittlerweile ein jahr vergangen
wieder ist weihnachten und die kinder
bleiben noch immer verschollen
wie ist es möglich gerade in dieser zeit
das unerträgliche zu ertragen
hier machen behandelt wird besonders
studierende vorbereitet und michaela
blankart kostka und auszeit vom verlust
schmerzt dem sommer ersehnte prozess
wegen des überfalls entpuppte sich zu
einem weiteren fehlschlag neuerdings
suchen die praxis ihre mädchen auch via
soziale netzwerke in der hoffnung die
kinder würden eines tages die
botschaften lesen was ist nicht scharf
erhielt sie das ist viel jährigen
quellen normal finden und das nicht dass
wir nicht als ihr denkt dass mir
ausdenke mögliche dafür zurückzuholen
das ist okay sagte wenn es nehme da sind
uns nämlich das jetzt in gedanken wo sie
langsam sich damit befassen
ich habe fast nur als mäßig fläche gebe
im moment einfach nicht akzeptieren
eine serie im free gesprochen
das sagt karin und nur an hat mit der
bande krimineller lüth opelfahrer sehe
ihn freigesprochen und das ist das war
für uns natürlich massive macht
ausgelöst
auf den kinderbetten liegen die
weihnachtsgeschenke vergangener jahre
noch immer eingepackt die sache liege
darf war sagt zu jahr denkt na ja ich
glaub das konto nicht dass das ist wie
wenn man sollte nicht der verschaffen ja
[Musik]
es ist frühling geworden karin traxel
ist wieder als lehrerin tätig als
vertretung an ihrer früheren schule das
unterrichten und der austausch mit den
schülerinnen und schülern helfen ihr
über den konstanten verlust schmerz
hinweg
[Musik]
vorschläge vom ausnahmezustand
wir haben ja irgendwie musste einfach
mit der neuen situation und bezieht
arrangiert und dass gott das arrangieren
das frische mangos westermann geschlecht
oder sojasoße mini schwieriger zieht
sowohl ihr macht es sicher schwierig sie
und auch wenn der alltag sich wieder
einschleicht und ein parallel eben
heranwächst der kampf um ihre kinder
geht weiter
wir begleiten karin traxel an eine
weitere von ihrer familie organisierte
solidaritätsaktion der verkauf von
wasser laternen viele lichter ein wunsch
die rückkehr der mädchen
die studie wie viel das was wir das
mittragen
und es geht weiter drei jahre sind
mittlerweile vergangen
zwischen zuversicht und zermürbung
aufgeben kommt nicht infrage
doch die anfängliche hoffnung auf ein
schnelles wiedersehen ist unterdessen
geschwunden
muss man denn die hoffnung vielleicht
einmal begraben
ich glaube aber das kam aber einfach
nicht es wird immer da sein
das ist ein fehler wenn es entsteht der
frau irgendwie abschließt direkt sie
irgendwo und was vorher nicht
der ausgang dieser geschichte bleibt
offen
das unerträgliche wird erträglich weil
der letzte funke hoffnung auf ein
wiedersehen mit den eigenen kindern
niemals erwischt